you're doing a fight sequence where the
person you're fighting because of the
nature of their costume can't see
anything you're the one has to be
watching for punches the usual stuff
when you're punching someone
it's where to punch how deep whatever
excuses you go me cuz I've recovered it
can't see as soon as it starts raining
all of your distance is messed with you
have to adjust immediately plus the
water is really cold and so as that my
honest it again an action and then
remembering everything you have to do
and try not to get hit in the face by a
guy wearing hot plastic gloves or vice
versa like you make that we did have a
lot more kind of complicated fight
sequences it's a fun collaboration I
really have a good time with those guys
trying to figure out like what we can
and cannot do more often than not it's
can I very rarely get it like now can't
do that from those guys we're seeing
like this takes much much stunt training
just to get the actual movement of all
the fights
so in this rooftop fight we have
ourselves looked up to these wires under
the suit we have this harness is super
tight and then we get strapped in right
to these Lynch's and they make us fly or
crash and for example in this fight team
Batman does this kick to Superman sends
them launched across the rooftop into
this awning rooftop skylight
you